so the question today is why would you
want to use lemon juice and apple cider
vinegar for your liver let's talk about
it the key element or factor in apple
cider vinegar is not the vitamins and
minerals and apple cider vinegar
it's the acetic acid so as far as the
quality goes and up cider vinegar you
get something that's organic you can get
Bragg's there's other organic versions
but commercial opposite of vinegar has
sometimes pesticides in it so just get
some in its quality okay what does
acetic acid do it helps suppress fat
storage now why does it prevent a person
from storing fat mainly what it does to
your blood Sugar's it actually improves
insulin sensitivity it makes insulin
more sensitive which means it reduces
insulin resistance which means it will
reduce insulin okay and anything that
does that will help prevent the storage
of fat and stabilize your blood sugars
and reduces fat on the liver because
fatty liver comes from high levels of
insulin but the real big benefit for
outside of vinegar is this it speeds up
digestion okay it helps you release bile
from your liver it helps the pancreas
release enzymes so let's say for example
you ate a meal and you feel bloated or
you have indigestion you want to take
apple cider vinegar it just helps to
speed up with the digestive juices the
flow of fluids through your liver
through the stomach through the small
intestine so if you have any doubts try
it yourself and you'll see that it will
work so these are the main key benefits
of adding up soda vinegar to your diet
now let's shift over to lemon okay so
you can do raw lemons or lemon juice in
a bottle just realize that if you're
consuming lemon juice in a bottle it's
cooked it's pasteurized and anything
that you heat you destroy enzymes and
you destroy certain vitamins you're
going to greatly lower the vitamin C
when you do that there's other benefits
to lemon juice that go beyond vitamin C
but you're not going to get a lot of
vitamin C if you're getting it from a
bottle and as a side note if you're
gonna get lemon juice in a bottle make
sure you get an organic version not the
one that you usually get at the grocery
store that has the
preservatives get something just with
lemon juice and water so there's several
benefits of lemon juice one is if it's
raw
you're getting a lot of good vitamin C
so vitamin C is very very important
especially to the liver
it's a powerful antioxidant and there's
a lot of oxidation and free radical
damage going on the liver so vitamin C
is very important in reducing that
oxidative effect that happens in the
liver vitamin C also will increase
glutathione which is a another powerful
antioxidant in the body especially in
your liver and even now glutathione is
not made inside the mitochondria the
little energy factories it's used by the
mono Kandra as a very important
antioxidant and you should probably
check out some of the videos I have on
the mitochondria I put a link down below
on that topic alright next thing lemon
juice protects against liver damage
let me just has a lot of phytonutrients
not just vitamins and certain minerals
these phytonutrients are very necessary
in protecting the cells against all the
chemicals that are involved I mean think
about it your liver is the main Oregon
to detoxify poisons and chemicals and it
needs antioxidants not just the ones
that your body makes but you need them
from the diet as well and lemons provide
a good source of antioxidants and citric
acid decreases oxalates okay and
oxalates actually can form kidney stones
they can actually form crystals that
cause pain in certain parts of the body
and citric acid helps prevent those and
this is one of the reasons why if you're
doing keto and then fasting this is this
would be a really good drink to consume
for the benefits of apple cider vinegar
and also the benefits to reduce oxalates
and one more benefit that lemon has is
its anti-inflammatory properties
when a person has a fatty liver their
inflammation goes up and that can
develop all sorts of buildup of collagen
as scar tissue which eventually turns
into cirrhosis so anything that reduces
inflammation would be a good thing now
there's many different ways that you can
consume this you can take out the cider
vinegar in a pill
there's even lemon powder
what I do personally is I take between
one and two ounces of lemon juice it's
usually two ounces and then I'll mix
that with two tablespoons of apple cider
vinegar in about 16 ounces of water okay
and I'll just drink that down I normally
like to consume this mixture after
dinner maybe about 6 or 7 o'clock at
night some people like to take a smaller
version and consume that before meals
it's really up to you you can test it
out different ways and sometimes I'll
add a scoop of wheatgrass juice powder
to this mixture which just adds more
nutrients and then there's other times
that I consume my wheatgrass juice
powder by itself in water in the morning
very early in about a 16-ounce jar so
I'll do that a little bit early in the
day and I'll have this more in the
evening and this seems to really help
digestion so as you doing in a minute
fasting to meals and one meal and you
feel like you're just a little bit
stuffed or you feel a full sensation or
bloating the combination of both of
these in some water can really help to
enhance digestion and take the stress
off the liver all right guys thanks for
watching so if you want more knowledge
on how to create a healthy body
subscribe now and get daily
notifications daily notifications that
sounds weird well I'll just remind you
on a daily basis about that